hey everyone welcome to my podcast and
this series is called a high school
memories my name is tuana Huka and I
will be your host today so without
further Ado let's let's dive into
today's episode and embark on a great
journey together get ready to be engaged
entertained and
inspired today's topic will be about
bullying in
schools So today we're going to dive
deep into the important issue of
bullying in
schools we'll discussed the causes
consequences and effective strategies to
combat this uh pervasive problem
bullying is a complex issue that affects
millions of students
worldwide to begin let's talk about the
causes of bullying in
schools bullying doesn't happen in a
vacuum it's often rooted in various
causes and understanding these causes is
crucial to addressing the problem it
happens because some kids might not
understand how it feels to be in someone
else's shoes or they might do it because
they think it's cool or their friends
are doing it children may also bully
others due to insecurities seeking
attention or wanting to feel more
powerful bullying is a complex problem
and it doesn't just happen randomly it
occurs for various reasons and
understanding these reasons is vital for
finding a solution one major cause is a
lack of
empathy uh in some cases bullying can be
a learned
behavior children may witness aggression
or mistreatment at home or in media
leading them to mimic these actions at
school plus with the internet we also
have cyber bullying now making it easier
for bullies to harass their victims
anonymously now that we've touched on
the causes let's talk about the
consequences of
bullying bullying can have severe and
Lasting consequences for both the victim
and the perpetrator
for the victim it can result in
emotional psychological and physical
dramaa uh they may experience anxiety
depression low self-esteem and even
resort to self harm as a way to escape
the
pain the
consequences don't stop at the
victims uh belies themselves face
significant
replications um so the consequences for
the bullies themselves are also
significant they may face disciplinary
action legal consequences or damage to
their own mental health uh bullying
affects the school environment too
creating an atmosphere or fear and
insecurity that can Hinder learning and
personal growth for all students
bullying can create a cycle of violence
that hampers the bu's own growth and
development uh so having discussed the
causes and consequences let's now turn
our attention to effective strategies to
combat
bullying to effectively combat about
bullying it requires a collective effort
from schools parents and
communities uh prevention is the
Cornerstone and it begins by fostering a
culture or empathy respect and
inclusivity here are some strategies to
consider uh so the first uh strategy is
is education and awareness so uh schools
should provide uh comprehensive
anti-bullying
education uh creating an understanding
of what bullying is uh so it's a harmful
effect and how to prevent
it so the second strategy is support
system uh robust uh support systems
should be in place including uh
consuling services and peer support
programs to help both victims and the
bullies uh so the third strategy is the
reporting
mechanism uh and so we need to encourage
students to report incidents safely and
anonymously ensuring that uh School
staff keeps these reports uh
seriously uh so the children can't be
scared to report uh a letter or
something against uh the
bullies uh the fourth uh strategy is
adult supervision so we increase adult
supervision uh particularly in areas
where bullying is likely to occur such
as the playground or online
spaces the fifth uh
strategy is the pure
environment Empower students to stand up
against bullying and safe places and
supportive
manner uh teach them to be allies not
bystanders words uh the sixth strategy
is cyber bullying
awareness uh so we need to address cyber
bullying by uh teaching digital
citizenship and responsible uh online
Behavior so the parents of uh the
children need to take care of what the
children are looking or what watching
online the seventh uh strategy is uh
consequences for
bullies uh so we need to implant fear
and consistent consequences for bullies
to
discourage such
Behavior so the last strategy we'll be
discussing today is Parental involvement
so we need to engage engage uh parents
in anti-bullying efforts as they play a
critical role in addressing the issue at
home uh so in conclusion bullying in
schools is a serious and pervasive issue
with profound
consequences uh by understanding its
causes addressing its
consequences and implementing effective
strategies we can create safer and more
inclusive uh School environments where
all students uh can feel
safe uh thank you so much for joining us
on this episode of high school memories
it's been an incredible journey and
we're so glad you came along for the
ride until next time take care and
remember that your voice matters and
keep speaking up
together we can make a positive impact
in the lives of young people and build a
brighter future free from
bullying